[Musique]
bonjour Olivier Paco bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de loise apparenté au groupe les
républicains et professeurs agrégé
d'histoire géographie évidemment ça a
son importance dans les thèmes qu'on va
aborder mais d'abord on l'a vu dans le
journal lactus arrête ce conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas Emmanuel Macron hier
a jugé que le conflit au ProcheOrient
pouvait être un élément de division en
France si on gère mal cette situation
est-ce que vous le craigz aussi oui il
faut surtout pas minorer les les risques
de de de dissension lié effectivement
aux images ou aux informations ou aux
fausses informations qui peuvent être
diffusées il suffit pour cela de d'aller
parfois sur les réseaux sociaux et je
suis stupéfait de de lire certains
commentaires euh juste après
effectivement l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas du du 7 octobre j'ai lu des choses
qui m'ont qui m'ont glacé des froids euh
h de la part de de de nombreuses
personnes qui sont pour certaines issu
de immigration proche ou pas du tout et
donc oui effectivement je pense que il y
a un ferment de de de dissension
profonde liée au conflit
israélo-palestinien
Emmanuel Macron qui appelle aussi à ne
pas importer le conflit est-ce qu'avec
la recrudescence des actes antisémites
qu'on constate en France depuis le 7
octobre l' elle n'est pas déjà
là oui elle était elle était déjà là
elle n'est pas arrivée le 7 octobre au
matin mais effectivement il y a il y a
un espèce de focus alors le message de
la France doit être clair la France est
l'ami d'Israël mais la France et depuis
longtemps pense que la solution passe
par la diplomatie que un État
palestinien doit voir le jour mais que
Israël a le droit de se défendre et et
l'attaque terroriste islamiste du Hamas
est impardonnable donc on ne doit pas
faire d'amalgame on ne met pas sur la
même position Israël et le Hamas mais on
est très clair hein dans la condamnation
et aussi dans le fait qu'on n'oublie pas
le peuple palestinien et que l'État
palestinien doit voir le jour on l'a vu
dans le journal hier avait lieu les
obsèques de Dominique Bernard on le
disait vous êtes prof vous d'histoire
géographie comme l'été Samuel pati comme
le visait euh l'assaillant d'as avant de
s'en prendre à Dominique Bernard ce
professeur de français qu'est-ce que
vous avez ressenti il y a une semaine
quand vous aveit appris euh l'assassinat
de Dominique
Bernard d'abord de
l'eroid puis euh je me suis dit qu'on
avait franchi un cran alors il y a pas
de gradation hein entre euh l'horreur de
la décapitation de Samuel pati et euh
euh l'assassinat euh de Dominique
Bernard mais il y a quand même eu une
évolution à savoir que
lorsque le terroriste s'en est pris à
Samuel paatti c'était suite à un cours à
un appel à la haine lancé par un parent
d'élèves qui visait spécifiquement le
cours et une présentation de caricature
de Mahomet là l'assaillant est rentré
dans l'école pour tuer du prof avant on
voulait tuer du flic là on veut buter du
prof et donc on s'attaque au savoir en
général donc effectivement on a franchi
un cran
dans la haine de ce que nous sommes et
et particulièrement les preuves
d'histoire qui sont principalement visé
alors pourquoi mais parce que l'histoire
est la matière qui permet enfin le
professeur d'histoire donne un trousseau
de clé une lanterne pour mieux
comprendre le monde d'hier mais aussi
d'aujourd'hui or les terroristes
islamistes ont un but clair et net c'est
l'obscurantisme c'est faire régner une
chape sombre sur notre démocratie nos
principes nos valeurs démocratiques il
s'attaquent d'abord à ça et donc ceux
qui tiennent la lanterne c'est-à-dire
notamment les professeurs d'histoire
géographie sont devenus des cibles donc
ils doivent être protégés comme tous les
autres professeurs mais effectivement
ils sont devenus encore plus des cibles
la la sœur de Samuel pati étit
auditionné par les sénateurs cette
semaine puisqu'il y a une mission une
commission d'enquête justement sur les
agressions dans saenseignant elle a
laissé entendre que la mort de son frère
n'avait pas changé grand-chose voir rien
changé vous le pensez aussi alors
malheureusement oui euh et moi ce qui
m'a le plus choqué euh dans l'affaire
Samuel Patti et ses suites c'est le fait
que l'on devait rebaptiser le collège du
nom de Samuel Patti et que ça ne se fait
pas pour ne pas
euh vexer ou froisser quelques
susceptibilité c'est incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible et il faut passer
outre ce collège doit s'appeler Samuel
pati
mais c'est quoi c'est de la lâcheté
politique ah oui oui oui oui je pense
que la lâcheté alors elle est politique
mais la lâcheté elle est général dans
notre société hein on a peur d'affirmer
certaines valeurs on a peur d'affirmer
certaines valeurs contre certaines
personnes une forme de culpabilisation
vis-à-vis du monde musulman vis-à-vis
des terroristes islamistes faut dire
très clairement les choses oui et alors
je vais vous donner un exemple précis
hier j'ai été stupéfait en regardant
l'interview de Gabriel hatal d'une
question de Caroline rou qui concernait
la euh
euh le fait que certains jeunes qui
avaient fait des alertes à la bombe on
était venu alors qu'ils avaient 12 13
ans on était venus pour euh les
interpeller bon la façon dont madame rou
a posé sa question m'a stupéfait elle
fait partie elle fait partie et les
journalistes font partie le monde
intellectuel fait partie justement de
cette démission de cette lâcheté
collective tolérance zéro tolérance zéro
c'est c'est ce que lui a répondu Gabriel
Atal qui qui a dit qui a dit que lui
voit pas de problème à qu'on vieller des
jeunes de 12 1 ansil av commis des
délits et que il fallait qu'il montre
l'exemple vous êtes elle est suffisante
la fermeté du M vous la prouvez en tout
cas ce discours de gabrielal oui je
préfère effectivement la la fermeté
verbale mais aussi le pragmatisme sur la
BA par exemple de gabrieltal au
dogmatisme et à l'évanescence de de PAP
oui je pense que
gabrielal a trouvé les mots et a trouvé
les actes changement oui
cl bien sûr il y a quand pas soutien du
gouvernement hein mais mais Fran non
c'est pour ça que je vous pose la
question Gabriel Atal aussi il a
afficher son soutien aux enseignants
parce qu'on l'a vu dans l'affaire de
Samuel paatti il y avait eu un manque
très clair de soutien de C hiarchie
voire de ses collègue mais de sa
hiérarchie est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que Gabriel hatal il veut
clairement tourner cette cette page du
pas de
vaguisme alors Jean-Michel Blanquer
n'avait cessé de le répéter oui il faut
mettre fin au pas de vague
j'ai l'impression qu'on est sur la bonne
voie mais vous savez le mamouth entre
guillemets dont parlait Claude Allègre
jadis il est très lourd et dans
l'administration de l'éducation
nationale effectivement il va falloir
que Gabriel hatal insuffle beaucoup de
choses qui manque pour l'instant parce
que je pense que le exist en vous avez
vous avez peur que les professeurs ne
suivent pas que l'administration ne
suive pas que les syndicats ne le
suivent pas je je suis plus confiant sur
la volonté des professeurs effectivement
de secouer le cocotier de l'injustice et
de la lâcheter je suis beaucoup moins
euh sûr de cette volonté dans la part de
de de la haute
administration beaucoup moins
oui vous êtes on va revenir juste un mot
sur la protection des établissements
scolaires puisque c'est aussi une
question hein donc Gabriel Atal a
rencontré les collectivités cette
semaine puisque c'est eux qui ont en
charge les établissements scolaires
est-ce qu'il faut mieux les protéger et
comment mieux les protéger jusqu'où il
faut aller al il faut certainement mieux
les protéger après chaque département
chaque région est un cas particulier moi
dans l'IS vous savez on a mis en place
la vidéo surveillance ou la vidéo
protection depuis très longtemps depuis
très longtemps et et ça marche donc oui
il faut pas hésiter effectivement à
mieux protéger sans pour autant all
jusqu'à la reconnaissance faciale par
exemple pourquoi pas pourquoi pas si ça
peut sauver des vies évidemment oui ça
ne me gêne pas du tout on va parler dans
quelques instants de la loi tion mais
d'abord pour faire le lien entre les
deux sujets l'exécutif affirme que dans
l'affaire de l'attaque d'aras il n'y a
pas eu de faille sur le suivi de
l'assaillant qui était un étranger qui
est arrivé en France à l'âge de 6 ans
qu'il n'y avait pas de signe
avantcoureur de sa volonté de passer à
l'acte est-ce que vous y
croyez il y a forcément une faille parce
que cet homme n'est pas devenu un tigre
violent du jour au lendemain hein donc
si il y a eu une faille et j'avais été
un petit peu gêné des propos du ministre
de l'Intérieur le lendemain où répondant
à cette question il avait dit non il y a
pas eu de faille bien au contraire bien
c'est le bien au contraire qui m'avait
profondément choqué donc oui il y a eu
une faille et effectivement ces
individus fichs dont on sait qu'ils sont
dangereux dont on sait qu'ils ont été
violents alors là on s' tarde sur le
fait que
ce ce monstre a été violent avec sa
maman bon dont on sait que ces gens sont
violents effectivement il faut trouver
les moyens pour les rendre
inoffensifs l'exécutif qui affirme que
si le projet de loi immigration avait
été en vigueur il aurait permis
l'expulsion justement de cet assaillant
d'aras le projet de loi immigration il
arrive au Sénat le 6 novembre on va en
parler tout de suite avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Quentin
[Musique]
calm bonjour Quentin bonjourien bonjour
Olivier Pacco bonjour et Quentin après
l'attentat d'aras Géral Harman a
souligné l'importance de son son projet
de loi immigration notamment en matière
de lutte contre le terrorisme voilà on
parle de ce projet de loi immigration
depuis plus d'un an l'idée initiale he
c'était un texte avec deux jambes
efficacité dans la lutte contre
l'immigration mais aussi intégration par
le travail dans la lutte contre
l'immigration illégal hein bien sûr et
en dans l'autre plan l'intégration par
le travail l'examen de ce texte a été
suspendu au printemps dernier après la
réforme des retraite le sujet était trop
inflammable selon la majorité de la
droite et du centre ici au Sénat qui
avait demandé à ce que on retarde
l'examen de ce texte mais donc depuis
l'attentat de la semaine dernière
géralde Darmanin revient à la charge
avec ce texte on l'a lu par exemp dans
le monde cette semaine depuis vendredi
le ministre de l'Intérieur Martelle que
le projet de loi immigration aurait
permis d'expulser l'assassin Dominique
Bernard avant qu'il n'agisse d'ailleurs
le ministre de l'Intérieur l'a redit
hier sur BFM TV on écoute gerérald
harant est-ce qu'il aurait pu être
expulsé la réponse est oui article 10 du
projet de loi que je présente devant le
Parlement si quelqu'un trouble l'ordre
public ça veut pas dire qu'il est
condamné trouble l'ordre public il s'en
prend un policier il violente sa femme
il trafique de la drogue il trouble
l'ordre public il peut-être expulser du
territoire national aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas cette mesure et mardi Géral hermanin
a donc fait de nouvelles propositions
pour aller encore plus loin sur ce texte
oui notamment avec une disposition qui
permette le retrait du titre de séjour
lorsqu'une personne je cite adhère à une
idéologie djihadiste radicale c'est
comme ça qu'elle été explicité
l'amendement qui sera donc sans doute
déposé par le Gouvernement pour aller
dans ce sens lorsque le texte arrivera
au Sénat d'ailleurs au Sénat on
accueille cette proposition de façon
plutôt favorable écoutez à notre micro
la rapporteur Muriel Jourda cette
semaine il y a déjà dans le texte la
possibilité de retirer un titre
lorsqu'une personne n'adhère pas aux
valeurs de la République on pense que le
djihadisme est quand même assez éloigné
des valeurs de la République ou des
principes de la République donc il me
semble que le texte devrait pouvoir le
permettre sans autre sans autre
précision mais bien sûr tout ça doit se
regarder autre proposition de géralde
Darmanin rallonger la durée de placement
en centre de rét tenstion administrative
ça passerait de 3 à 18 mois maximum pour
les fichiers S ou les personnes
délinquantes alors sur ce point la
Commission s'est montrer plus réservé on
verra ce qui se passera en séance le
texte qui est attendu début de l'examen
le 6 novembre au Sénat une question pour
vous Olivier Paco on voit le
gouvernement qui semble vouloir donner
des gages à la droite avec ce projet de
loi immigration est-ce que vous saluez
les annonces de cette semaine de géralde
de darmanant
oui mais le fond du problème sur ce
texte c'est les articles 3 et 4 qui
permettent de régulariser des sans
papiers qui travaillent dans les métiers
en tenstion oui dans les métiers en
tension que ce soit dans les métiers en
tension ou pas ça n'a aucune importance
le problème de base c'est que ces gens
sont hors la loi et on parle d'éducation
parle de l'école une des bases justement
de notre société c'est qu'on doit
respecter la loi à partir du moment où
on passe la gomme le tipex sur
effectivement un parcours qui a violé
les lois de la République je ne suis pas
d'accord donc voilà on comprend les Lig
rouge qui se dessine pour la droite
sénatoriale enfin pour les LR c'est cet
article 3 vous n'en voulez pas du tout
dans le texte les centristes eux ils
sont favorables alors même si ils disent
qu'on peut passer par du règlementaire
il y a donc là une fracture au sein de
la majorité sénatoriale sur ce texte
alors écoutez je pense qu'au sein des
centristes les choses sont un petit peu
plus compliquées que ça comme toujours
mais ça peut être effectivement un point
de dissenion oui
et moi personnellement je ne vonnerai
pas cet article il y a une impasse
pardon allez-y qu il une imp passe aussi
sur ce thème sur cet article 3 c'est que
et bien la macronie le groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale y
tient particulièrement ils disent que
certains d'entre eux ne voteront pas le
projet immigration s'il n'y a pas
l'article 3 dedans il y a une impasse
politique qui se dessine sur ce projet
de immigration on est d'accord oui je ne
voterai pas ce texte si l'article 3 est
dedans c'est clair et c'est net et c'est
le cas du groupe LR au Sénat donc
effectivement minor vous risquez d'être
minoritaire c'est possible est on peut
être minoritaire en en restant fidèle à
ses valeurs hein vous savez hein mais
est-ce que dans le contexte actuel on on
a parlé hein de toutes ces questions de
l'attaque du fait de Géral que Géral
hermanin compte sur ce texte pour
pouvoir plus facilement expulser les
radicalisés est-ce que vous n'allez pas
vous les LR vous décrédibiliser à ne pas
voter un texte qui durcit les mesures
que vous réclamez depuis des mois voir
des annéesime pas ce chantage voilà
c'est une forme de chantage de la part
du du ministre de l'intérieur ça
fonctionne pas comme ça peut-être que
lui à ce type de fonctionnement
intellectuel euh euh le fait de sans
arrêt renoncer à certaines valeurs au
nom deeux non et euh la loi mais là il
là il vous tend clairement la main
Quentin l'a rappelé il vous tend la main
Gérald d'Anin il dit que la quasi
totalité de vos propositions il les
soutiendra il a même fait un un pas sur
l'aide médicale d'urgence vers vous là
il a annoncé cette semaine euh d'autres
mesures alors dites-nous par exemple
puisquil veut intégrer au projet de loi
immigration une disposition qui permet
de retirer son titre de séjour à un
étranger qui adhère à une idéologie
djihadiste est-ce que vous soutiendrez
cette mesure mais madame joura vous l'a
dit c'est déjà dans le texte donc il en
rajoute hein il remet une petite couche
oui j'y suis favorable évidemment mais
là globalement dans le texte il y a cet
article 3 qui est effectivement pour
nous euh inacceptable donc nous ne
voterons pas le texte s'il y a l'article
3 et encore une autre question sur cet
article 3 est-ce que vous appelez vos
collègues députés à et bien déposer une
motion de censure en tout cas à voilà se
joindre à une possible motion de censure
si si le texte a allé jusqu'au bout à
l'Assemblée nationale je sais pas si on
a vu que sur cette question de
l'Immigration Éric chti voilà était très
véhément aussi oui non mais il y a un
vrai problème avec l'immigration et on
va en être au 20e ou 22e texte sur
l'immigration depuis
1986 c'est c'est bien la preuve que on
n'arrive pas à résoudre le problème qui
est plus un problème d'intégration que
d'immigration mais à la base c'est parce
qu'il y a une immigration qui est trop
importante et qu'on narrive plus
effectivement à intégrer alors ce texte
pourra ponctuellement régler quelques
problèmes mais le fait de régulariser
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui ont violé la loi non seulement c'est
un appel d'air inconditionnel pour vous
c'est des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui seraient régularisé avec
l'article 3 potentiellement aujourd'hui
et demain bien sûr c'est pas du tout ce
que dit geréral ou mais bien sûr non
mais oui qui parle de quelques milliers
parce qu'il a quand même des qu' a quand
même des conditions c'està-dire il faut
avoir résider en France mais vous savez
qu'on peut le faire vous savez qu'on
peut le faire la loi permet actuellement
de bon par les préfets ont cette
possibilité donc il me semblait que
aller plus loin c'était plus qu'un
symbole et je pense que c'est une erreur
voilà un dernier mot Quentin sur la
question du référendum oui tout à fait
effectivement on voit que les groupes LR
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
veulent étendre la possibilité
d'organiser un référendum en y intégrant
les questions migratoires les LR vous
vous avez déjà prévu des créneaux au
Parlement pour examiner ces textes
constitutionnels ce sera le 7 et 12
décembre dans les deux chambres du
Parlement ça fait partie du marché que
vous souhaitez conclure avec le
gouvernement vous voulez aller plus loin
sur cette révision constitutionnelle
c'est
ça écoutez je suis pas convaincu que la
révision constitutionnelle sur ce point
précis
va profondément bouleverser la donne
vous êtes pas d'accord avec bon donc
c'est lui qui insiste beaucoup sur cette
question depuis plusieurs mois je je je
pense que c'est pas le problème
essentiel sincèrement de pouvoir étendre
la possibilité de consulter les Français
sur l'immigration alors non mais étendre
le champ du référendum oui est-ce que un
référendum sur l'immigration règlera la
problématique j'en suis pas persuadé
parce que je connais déjà la réponse au
référendum l'immense majorité des
Français diseront qu'il y a un problème
avec l'immigration qu'il y a
certainement trop d'immigrés la vraie
problématique c'est de mettre fin
justement à cette immigration trop
importante et là c'est pas une question
de référendum c'est une question de
volonté mais les LR ils veulent aussi un
une révision constitutionnelle pour
s'affranchir des règles européennes en
matière de d'immigration pour que le
droit européen ne prime plus sur le
droit français là vous êtes d'accord ou
oui oui je pense que le droit européen
doit rester à sa
place une dernière question si si on a
le temps est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque
avec tout ce débat qu'on a autour de
l'immigration d'assimiler immigration
terrorisme et délinquence est-ce qu'il y
a pas un risque que le débat public
brouille complètement cette image de
l'immigration alors peut-être mais vous
savez dans dans le texte sur
l'immigration justement moi j'ai déposé
un amendement pour créer une médaille de
l'intégration c'està-dire que pour les
immigrés qui se sont de façon exemplaire
intégrés pour les valoriser je pense
qu'on peut tout à fait effectivement
trouver un juste milieu je pense qu'on
peut trouver un juste milieu merci
Quentin à tout à l'heure merci oui tout
à l'heure on reviendra voilà sur la
sécurité en France les risques
d'attentat effectivement et le sentiment
d'insécurité aussi qui progresse en
France ce sera suiv dans le club tout à
l'heure Quentin on va voir l'actualité
dans nos régions Olivier Pacot on va à
CLA Montferrand retrouver Gill lalose
bonjour Gill merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous directeur des édition du PIT d'ome
à la rédaction du journal La Montagne on
en parlait tout à l'heure g les alertes
à la bombe se multiplient dans les
aéroports dans les gardes dans les
musées et du coup vous allez nous parler
de la sécurisation de ces grands
événements et de ces lieux publics tout
à fait c'est ce qui fait la Une
aujourd'hui de des journaux du groupe
Centre-France parce que hier une dizaine
de lycées du puid d'Ô ont été confinés
et évacués à chaque fois l'alerte
intrusion a été déclenchée dans ses
établissements scolaires après la
réception d'un mail faisant état d'une
menace venant de l'extérieur à l'instar
de nombreux autres aéroports français
ces derniers jours celui de Claire
Montferrand a été victime également dans
la journée d'hier d'une alerte à la
bombe et comme vous l'avez dit aéroport
établissement Scola musé sont frappés
par ces fausses allégations dont les
auteurs sont qualifiés de petit guignol
par Éric Dupont Moretti et c'est ces
fausses ces fausses alertes se
multiplient et impos un climat anxiogène
pendant le plan vigipiral qui a été
relevé depuis une semaine du niveau
sécurité renforcé à urgence attentat
monsieur le sénateur Paco alors que
matigon a appelé hier à la vigilance
sans céder à la peur comment vivre
sereinement alors que le risque zéro
n'existe pas comme on l'ont rappelit les
attaques terroristes à haras et à
Bruxell alors écoutez vous savez dans
mon département on a un aéroport
l'aéroport de Tillet ou Bovet Tillet et
bien en de jour on a effectivement eu
deux alertes à la bombe et alors ça a
perturbé le trafic aérien ça a embêté
tout le monde à savoir les passagers
mais aussi les habitants de la commune
les élus alors comment faire
effectivement il faut être
particulièrement sévère pour reprendre
les propos de Gabriel aptal sur les
auteurs
de ces mauvaises blagues qui ne sont pas
que des mauvaises blagues mal
interpellation dit Géral oui mais mais
il a eu raison donc il faut être d'une
fermeté extrême et il faut que la
justice elle même soit aussi d'une
fermeté extrême et d'une réactivité
totale et il faut aussi le faire savoir
faut faire ça savoir un tel a fait une a
provoqué une alerte à la bombe il est
condamné à et vraiment il faut que ce
soit clair et net malheureusement le
risque zéro non pas d'attentat mais de
mauvaise blagues n'existe pas et alors
très honnêtement je n'ai pas la solution
je pense que l'éducation et
l'information sont essentielles à ce
niveau-là et c'est vrai que pour des
grandes manifestations par exemple un
match de rugby une demi-finale de Coupe
du monde des grands spectacles he des
festival effectivement on peut avoir des
des situations particulièrement
compliquées c'est un vrai problème c'est
un vrai problème Gill vous avez une
autre question qui concerne la région
ver renal oui qu' on vient là sur le le
le champ politique puisque hier une
enquête de la cellule investigation de
Radio France a affirmé que quatre
proches collaborateurs qui travaillent
pour Laurent voquier le président LR de
la région auverne ronalpe ont des
missions éloignées de la collectivité et
notamment à Paris cela rejaillli sur le
climat de la session du Conseil régional
qui a débuté hier et qui se poursuit
aujourd'hui à Lyon Laurent vquier a
réagi en annonçant je cite je sais que
c'est devenu un sport national de
diffuser de fausses rumeurs sur des élus
surtout à certains moments et il a
pointé du doigt des informations
mensongères erronées et malhonnêtes les
réactions de l'opposition régionale
n'ont pas tardé Fabienne Grebert pour
les écologistes estime que dans son
obsession pour la présidentielle Laurent
vequier semble un peu trop s'inspirer de
François Fillon alors que Najad Valou
Belkassem au nom du PS pour elle c'est
une illustration de plus de cet usage
très particulier que Laurent voquier
fait de la région au service de ses
ambitions personnelles monsieur le
sénateur Paco dans les candidat
potentiel pour les républicains à la
présidentielle est-ce que c'est un
nouveau coup dur pour Laurent voquier je
pense qu'il se serait bien passé de
cette publicité oui après nul n'est
au-dessus de la loi euh
donc j'ai entendu les propos de du
président de la région ronalp dont
acte rien de plus rien de plus merci
Gill merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on regarde la une de la montagne
risque sécuritaire la France sur ses
gardes c'est à la Une de votre journal
ce matin merci beaucoup Gilles d'avoir
été avec nous Laurent voquier justement
puisque Gilles en parlait vous êtes
plutôt proche de Xavier Bertrand vous
mais Laurent voquier il a fait un grand
pas en avant pour 2027 il y a quelques
semaines il s'avance trop pour
vous alors écoutez je sais pas si ça
avance trop parce que pendant un moment
on l'avait pas beaucoup vu donc
son ambition elle est légitime c'est un
homme politique de premier plan après il
faut effectivement pour la la droite
entre guillemets qu'elle réussisse à
trouver son champion ou sa championne
pas trop tard visiblement les leçons de
2022 doivent être retenues peut-être
l'ont-elles été très honnêtement il
faudra que les impétrants se fassent
connaître au plusut tôt et qu'il se
départagent il pourrait en faire partie
Xavier Bertrand pourrait en faire partie
parce que il a encore envie oui Xavier
Bertrand vous savez il incarne une une
pensée qui est le golisme social dont
notre pays a besoin et qui
malheureusement est quand même très
absent hein on a besoin d'ordre mais on
a aussi besoin de d'une justice sociale
on doit créer de la richesse mais on
doit la répartir effectivement à droite
ce discours là il est tenu avant tout
par Xavier Bertrand alors effectivement
en 2022 ça s'est pas passé comme on le
souhaitait mais il y aur peut-être une
voix pour pour 2027 mais c'est quoi le
départage parce que là on la primaire va
être clairement supprimée hein c'est ce
que Eric souti a laissé entendre comment
départage les candidats du coup je n'ai
pas de solution euh la solution jadis
c'était le grand chef qui par son
magistère moral intellectuel réussissait
à s'imposer à ses à ses proches
aujourd'hui là vous avez l'impression
qu'éicti il tente d'imposer Laurent
vquier au détriment de de David Lisnard
vous le
regrettez au moins il a eu le mérite de
la franchise il a affiché la couleur on
peut pas lui reprocher l'inverse
maintenant pour moi c'était pas
forcément la la meilleure des choses
donc je pense que la droite elle a un
problème là à ce niveau à résoudre he et
mais peut-être que le ou la candidate
n'est pas celui ou celle que l'on croit
pour l'instant peut-être que quelqu'un
se révélera et et vaut mieux parce que
sinon et vous pensez à Xavier bertr ah
je je pense que Xavier a toutes les
qualités oui et je le soutiens merci
Olivier Paco merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure